bonsoir nous sommes le 23 octobre il est
18h si vous nous suivez en direct
l'heure du journal de elle a rédaction
dans l'actualité locale la secrétaire
d'État chargée de la politique de la
ville en déplacement à Trappes une
visite pour constater les travaux
réalisés dans le cadre de l'enrue
l'Agence nationale pour la rénovation
urbaine
Guyancourt dans la grande guerre pour
célébrer le centenaire du premier
conflit mondial des habitants se sont
associés au service des archives
municipales une exposition est
actuellement à découvrir nous en parlons
avec nos invités notamment la
responsable de l'action culturelle sur
la commune et puis le haras national des
Bréviaires reçoit pour l'édition 2014
des nuits du haras Jean-François pignon
un spectacle équestre emprunt de poésie
douceur émotion et humour nous promet le
dresseur que nous avons bien sûr
rencontré de faits divers pour débuter
ce journal à Trappes tout d'abord ou
trois bus ont été détruits deux autres
endommagés un incendie elle s'est
déclarée dans la nuit de mercredi à
jeudi au dépôt de la société l'écart de
Versailles un seul départ de feu a été
identifié son origine ne serait pas
accidentelle elle l'enquête est en cours
et puis à coign un braquage hier soir
dans le magasin Giga Store en bordure de
la venue des arpents de malfaiteurs dont
l'important revolver se sont cachés dans
les toilettes du magasin à la fermeture
vers 19h l'agent de sécurité et les
quatre derniers employés présents ont
été surpris l'un d'entre eux a été
frappé 3000 € de recettes dérobées ainsi
que les téléphones portables des
salariés la direction qui se refuse
aujourd'hui à tout commentaire l'enquête
a été confiée à la division criminelle
du Service régional de police judiciaire
de Versailles
samedi 1er août 1914 la guerre est
déclarée contre l'Allemagne
guyancourtney alors qu'un village de 600
habitants mais les hommes doivent partir
au front alors que nous sommes dans le
centenaire de la grande guerre c'est de
cette histoire dont nous allons parler
avec Cathy Blondeau bonsoir vous êtes la
responsable de l'action culturelle de la
ville et avec Pascal Dubois bienvenue
vous êtes habitants de Guyancourt et
vous avez participé à l'élaboration
d'une exposition une exposition dont on
va tout de suite parler mais déjà pour
repréciser les choses on va retracer
toute l'histoire à travers l'exposition
de cette période de 4-1914 à 1918 vous
avez disposé de tous les documents pour
pouvoir être le plus fidèle et le plus
précis possible alors oui on a récolté
des documents à peu près plus de 200
documents pour pouvoir retracer
l'histoire de Guyancourt dans la Grande
Guerre donc qui se compose en trois
parties cette exposition une première
partie autour de la mobilisation
générale donc vraiment comment les
poilus sont partis à la guerre une
seconde partie qui est plutôt centrée
sur Guyancourt donc vraiment comment
l'aiguille en courtois entre 1914 et
1918 et enfin une dernière partie qui
est une partie beaucoup plus solennelle
donc vraiment ceux qui sont rentrés ou
non les combattants qui sont
rentrésiliens
mais les hommes ont dû partir sur le
front et puis pas seulement parce que
l'armée a aussi été très présente dans
la ville pendant cette période oui
c'est-à-dire que depuis en fait
1913 on a à Guyancourt décantonnements
qui se mettent en place pour que des
soldats venus d'un peu toute la France
se prépare à une éventuelle guerre
puisque bon à ce moment-là elle est pas
démarrée mais partout dans Europe elle
est latente et donc dès 1913 il y a des
cantonnements comme vous l'avez dit sur
600 en fait 640 habitants
200 Guyancourtois vont être mobilisés
vont partir au front
et presque sans lui en courtois
partiront dans les deux premières
semaines du conflit c'est un lourd tribu
pour la ville qui a aussi du pendant que
l'armée était présente logé nourrir les
loger des soldats il fallait les nourrir
il y avait plus les hommes pour
s'occuper des récoltes pour s'occuper
puisque Guyancourt était un virage un
village rural et donc ce sont les femmes
et les enfants essentiellement qui vont
s'en occuper avec
l'aide de de marin qui ont été mobilisés
on a pu l'identifier qu'environ 40
marins étaient venus aider prêter main
forte à la population locale
ils étaient parfois pas
très habile dans le maniement des
charrues et donc on a un certain nombre
de textes qui nous expliquent il a fallu
réparer beaucoup beaucoup de matériel
les textes justement quels sont les
types de documents dont vous avez réussi
à disposer son des cartes postales des
écrits alors peut-être que parce que un
certain nombre de textes on a fait appel
aux populations enfin aux habitants donc
certains habitants on peut retrouver des
cartes postales on peut retrouver des
lettres des textes on a également aux
archives municipales tout un ensemble de
documents sur la période à nouveau des
cartes postales quelques portraits
quelques photos mais c'est très rare les
photos surtout que bon le petit village
de Guyancourt et pas vraiment l'endroit
qu'on vient photographier on a des
photographies de la mairie mairie école
de l'église puis c'est à peu près tout
du centre-ville quoi la redoute de
Bouvier aussi on en a pas parlé alors la
redoute de Bouvier qui fait partie d'un
système de défense qui a été mis en
place mis au point après la guerre de
1870 et qui va plutôt servir de
cantonnement parce que les troupes
allemandes vont approcher à peu près à
50 km de Paris au nord-est puis ils vont
être poussés donc elles n'auront pas à
jouer leur à ce moment-là l'exposition
est à découvrir jusqu'au 14 décembre à
Guyancourt vous voyez quelques-uns des
documents qui sont qui sont présentés
lors de l'exposition comment vous avez
travaillé justement pour collecter ces
différents textes différents écrits
photos alors ces documents mais ils
viennent d'un d'un ensemble vaste de
sources les archives municipales les
archives départementales des Yvelines et
d'autres départements parce qu'au
Guyancourt on a des des gens des
habitants qui venaient déjà à l'époque
d'autres départements beaucoup de
Bretons notamment qui viennent des
Côtes-d'Armor et donc les archives
les documents les archives militaires
avec l'arrivée du centenaire
l'armée française a ouvert ses archives
ce qui nous a permis de trouver un
certain nombre d'éléments et par contre
pour tout ce qui est vie locale c'était
essentiellement archives municipales à
partir des recensements recensement de
population liste électorale mais
également des statistiques agricoles
énormément de statistiques agricoles
qu'on a pu travailler pour voir comment
évolue avait évolué la production
agricole pendant la guerre et puis aussi
les listes de recrutement des jeunes lui
en courtois ce qui a permis de faire ce
travail trouver ces 200 mobilisés et
puis des registres par exemple où on
listait progressivement le nombre de
chevaux de jument qui était encore dans
la commune et on voit que ce nombre il
va aller énormément diminuant au fur et
à mesure que les réquisitions prennent
ses chevaux pour les envoyer sur le
front et donc vous avez décantonnements
vous avez les hommes qui ne sont plus là
vous avez les femmes qui sont au travail
vous avez moins de chevaux donc la
situation pendant la guerre va empirer
d'année en année j'imagine
que pour la municipalité c'est un
plaisir de travailler avec des gens qui
sont calés comme ça et qui arrivent à
collecter des documents ça facilite le
travail c'est beaucoup plus facile
effectivement de passer directement
auprès des lieux en courtois pour
collecter ce type d'information ce sont
des passionnés de leur vie les aiment la
mettre en valeur et nous c'est un
plaisir de travailler avec eux pour
pouvoir mettre en valeur et faire
découvrir l'histoire de la ville donc se
servir aussi de cette exposition pour
faire découvrir aux plus jeunes parce
que c'est un témoignage il y a un
atelier qui a été proposé hier notamment
il y a aussi une conférence on peut
peut-être parler du programme qui se
déroule en parallèle de l'exposition
alors l'exposition offre plusieurs
événements autour de l'exposition
elle-même donc il y a effectivement eu
un atelier qui s'est déroulé hier donc
auprès des enfants il y a des ateliers
pour enfants assez régulièrement auprès
des scolaires de la ville de Guyancourt
où on fait une visite guidée de
l'exposition et après on fait un petit
atelier un petit atelier de cartes
postales donc les enfants sont amenés à
faire des collages
issus des images de la Grande Guerre et
après d'écrire une correspondance au dos
ceux qui veulent à côté de ça il y a
également une conférence qui va se
dérouler le 9 décembre à la bibliothèque
universitaire ça sera autour de
informations et censures dans la grande
guerre qui sera animé par Jean-Yves
Mollier on a également un autre
rendez-vous si vous souhaitez visiter
l'exposition il y a une visite guidée
qui se déroulera le vendredi 14 novembre
à 12h15 donc n'hésitez pas à réserver
voilà pour le programme complet et puis
à l'occasion de ces commémorations du
centenaire de la première guerre la
ville a aussi donné une place au travail
de mémoire de certains artistes la
mezzanine de l'hôtel de ville présente
jusqu'au 6 novembre les œuvres de
François Mahieu le reportage d'Aurélia
Debussy
donner une place au travail de mémoire à
travers l'art dans le cadre des
commémorations du centenaire de la
Grande Guerre la mezzanine de l'hôtel de
ville de Guyancourt accueille jusqu'au 6
novembre les œuvres de l'artiste
François Mahieu des sculptures créées à
partir de fragments
de bataille de la Première Guerre
mondiale homme nubilé depuis l'enfance
par la Grande Guerre François Mahieu
entame des recherches et très vite né le
besoin d'aller sur le terrain de
s'imprégner c'est ainsi qu'il croise le
chemin des Dames
j'étais comment dire
comme saisie par ce lieu je m'interdis
de de
faire toute fouille sur sur un terrain
sacré vraiment ça serait et puis
c'est stigmates sont tellement présents
pour qu'ils veulent peu vous voulez voir
marcher regarder ramasser
de cette terre que ressortent encore un
siècle plus tard les débris métalliques
collectés par l'artiste
je suis sensible à ce qui est je dirais
un peu déchiqueté brut ses éclats
à force de les manipuler j'ai voyais que
tu voyais autre chose certains fragments
je le disais un morceau de torse je
lisais une tête et il met apparu une
assemblée évident que j'allais
travailler sur la silhouette j'allais
travailler sur des corps redressés
relever
abîmés mais debout de ces 15 années
consacrées à l'exploration du Chemin des
Dames l'artiste a également entrepris un
travail de peinture je suis toujours
touché ému
bouleversé quand
j'arrive dans quand j'arrive de d'un
autre plateau que je vois cette ligne
d'horizon j'ai commencé à peindre sur
cet horizon
je ne suis pas dans la volonté de de
comment dire de traduire des scènes de
scènes de guerre ou autre c'est vraiment
une interprétation
ressentie
quand je suis dans mon atelier
cette exposition donne à saisir une
vision artistique de l'expérience de
guerre qui pour François Mahieu
s'inscrit dans une démarche d'éveil de
nos consciences
c'est votre exposition proposée à
Guyancourt autour de la grande guerre
une exposition artistique un mot
peut-être sur le travail qui est
présenté actuellement François
comme il a bien expliqué du Chemin des
Dames et en plus je tiens un souligner
que c'est une personne très agréable et
à travailler et à côtoyer
en plus à tout ce travail qui est mené
et puis bien sûr il y a l'autre
exposition dont nous parlions tout à
l'heure celles qui présente les archives
de la commune c'est jusqu'au 14 décembre
que va devenir cette exposition que vont
devenir c'est genre suivre collectés
après
et ben on verra vous êtes encore posé la
question c'est pas encore posé la
question mais on remarque déjà que
l'exposition fonctionne très bien auprès
des enfants et des adultes donc on
espère continuer peut-être le projet
peut-être autour d'un livre on verra
pour collecter un petit peu tous ces
témoignages juste une dernière question
pour conclure est-ce qu'il y a un
témoignage ou des choses qui sont
ressorties de cette exposition et qui
vous ont interpellé marqué que vous avez
découvert véritablement des témoignages
peut-être ou oui dans les témoignages
mais je dirais peut-être un des points
marquants qui
pour nous ça fait depuis donc cinq ans
que ces recherches ont débuté on a un
des poilus qui est mort pour la France
et qu'on a toujours pas trouvé auquel on
n'a pas trouvé d'informations il reste
un inconnu pour nous et ça c'est quelque
chose de
de marquant pour nous parce que c'est
des années qu'on cherche on trouve pas
merci à tous les deux d'être venu nous
parler donc de la grande guerre et de la
façon dont se lassait déroulé cela a été
vécu à Guyancourt avec aujourd'hui des
expositions découvrir merci encore nous
poursuivons le journal culture à présent
si l'avenir du Haras des Bréviaires est
encore en suspens leur et pour l'instant
au spectacle la dès ce weekend débute
l'édition 2014 et des nuits du haras
Jean-François Avignon considérait comme
le plus grand dresseur de chevaux au
monde va dévoiler un spectacle ou en
émotions pour toute la famille
troisième édition des Nuits du haras au
bréviaire un spectacle son et lumière
avec une thématique cette année et le
cinéma
par exemple Laurel et Hardy Mission
Impossible Star Wars
Moulin Rouge voilà chaque fois on essaye
de coller au thème du cinéma il est
spectacle c'est un
spectacle en plein développement ça
attire beaucoup en plus dans les
Yvelines on est un département où il y a
le plus de licenciés en équitation donc
les gens qui aiment le cheval oui les
spectacles équestre oui ça se développe
beaucoup
quatre soirées de représentation avec
comme invité d'honneur celui que l'on
présente comme l'un des meilleurs
dresseurs au monde Jean-François pignon
avec ses chevaux il interviendra trois
fois dans le spectacle un travail tout
en finesse sans poésie presque en
silence un savoir-faire magique
et nous avons rencontré le dresseur
invité pour cette édition des Nuits du
haras en françois Pignon un entretien
mené par Yolaine Thorez avec cette
autodidacte devenue aussi acteur et
réalisateur en mars dernier vous l'avez
sans doute vu avec gazelle
nous sommes au rang national des
Bréviaires c'est ici que se dérouleront
les nuits du Haras du 23 au 26 octobre
et je suis en compagnie de l'invité
d'honneur Jean-François pignon bonjour
alors vous êtes l'un des plus grands
dresseurs de chevaux mondialement connu
c'est à l'âge de 12 ans quel est votre
passion lorsque donc votre père vous
achète une jument appelée gazelle la
vous louez une relation assez
particulière avec l'animal qu'est-ce qui
vous plaît dans ce rapport au cheval
c'est un rapport sans tradition avec
une méthode qui est venue après une
observation des chevaux entre eux et
puis
ce qui m'a vraiment plu à l'époque c'est
que mon père m'a en effet offert ce
cadeau mais il y avait aucune contrainte
ni de la part du cheval mais de la part
de mon père il m'a vraiment laissé la
liberté d'expression avec cet animal de
cette passion ensuite des spectacles des
spectacles qui rencontrent un réel
succès parce que justement vous avez une
méthode assez particulière de dressage
en liberté est-ce que vous pouvez nous
en dire plus un peu sur cette méthode
c'est très simple en fait et c'est très
logique
parce qu'en fait je me suis dit pour
parler
et être efficace avec un anglais autant
lui parler anglais et c'est exactement
la même chose avec les chevaux je me
suis dit je vais essayer de de
comprendre le langage cheval pour
essayer de parler cheval donc tout ce
qui est claquement de langue et chose
comme ça finalement moi je l'utilise pas
et j'essaie d'utiliser leur subtilité et
je dis bien j'essaye parce que je pense
que je serai toujours qu'un être humain
au milieu des chevaux mais ce que je
sais c'est que en m'appliquant à essayer
de respecter leur langage je me
rapproche d'eux et c'est ce que j'essaie
d'enseigner aussi au mieux
dans les années 2000 ensuite vous entrez
dans un un nouveau monde celui du cinéma
parce que pour nous raconter un petit
peu vos expériences la première en 2007
dans le film danse avec lui alors danse
avec lui c'est rigolo parce qu'on est
venu me chercher dans un premier temps
comme dresseur de chevaux uniquement et
ce qui s'est passé c'est que la
réalisatrice qui est
très concentré sur la
à gérer la véracité des images qu'elle
allait mettre dans ce film c'est dit que
l'idéal aurait été de boire pas
seulement en tant que dresseur mais
aussi dans le rôle du dresseur de
chevaux et en 2010 donc vous décidez de
poursuivre un peu l'aventure en
réalisant votre propre long-métrage il
s'appelle gazelle un nom pas choisi au
hasard il s'agit de votre première
jument
qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que ça raconte
ma vie tout simplement et
le film est intitulé gazelle parce que
je raconte tous les grands virages de ma
vie dans ce film j'ai pas retracé
40 ans de vie en
en deux heures sans prendre le principal
simplement et gazelle étonnamment
finalement a fait partie de tous les
grands virages de ma ville notamment
cette possibilité de devenir artiste
équestre et d'en faire un vrai métier et
par la suite bien plus tard j'ai une
dizaine d'années plus tard elle m'a
aussi permis de croire en Dieu
aujourd'hui comment justement le fait de
croire en Dieu m'a amené à enfin je
dirais aimer les humains très bien
gazelle je précise qui sera d'ailleurs
projeté dimanche soir
suite à la dernière représentation le 26
octobre il y aura ensuite un débat avec
vous merci Jean-François pignon nous
avons accordé un petit peu de temps
alors vous le savez donc le spectacle
l'inoui du haras c'est du 23 au 26
octobre ici au haras national des
Bréviaires
loisir à présent pendant les vacances
des ateliers sont proposés au plus
jeunes et à Mani les hameaux ces
derniers se sont essayés au Kapla c'est
célèbre planchettes un atelier de
construction annoncé comme monumental du
côté de Manille les hameaux auquel nous
avons pris part
une fois qu'on a ça on installe à un
verre au fond les cinq petites espaces
et un verre de intéressant petit espace
tout ça c'est un étage on va monter
comme ça en tout de cet étage les
consignes sont données par Cloé c'est
parti les yeux rivés sur leur
planchettes de bois de couleur
différente les enfants font évoluer leur
motifs là on est en train de faire un
temple chinois donc là on est en train
de faire des agrafes pour s'accrocher
ensemble et on fait des tours en fait
j'aime bien fabriquer des choses oui et
aussi après ça va devenir joli mais
avant que cela ne devienne jolie il faut
s'armer de patience et le secret d'une
réalisation réussie doucement prends ton
temps
n'est pas pressé prends ton temps ça
c'est compliqué parce qu'on doit mettre
les kaplas debout donc ça enfin c'est
fragile pour les guider l'une des 12
animatrices du centre Kapla de Paris car
avec ce jeu de construction on ne
plaisante pas ce sont des planchettes en
pain des Landes toutes sont identiques
si on les met l'une à côté les unes à
côté des autres ils ont toutes la même
dimension et il y a des rapports de
proportions
c'est à dire qu'on a trois épaisseurs
ils font une largeur
et cinq largeur
qui font une longueur
et à partir de là c'est un peu un nombre
magique on peut construire tout ce qu'on
veut tout ce que l'on veut ce mercredi
c'était un temple une girafe un bateau
les plus petits vont faire beaucoup
d'algorithmes où ils vont répéter un
rythme côté plat côté plat côté plat par
exemple ce qu'on va faire sur les
bateaux les plus grands on va faire des
choses un peu plus complexes les girafes
c'est pas forcément ce qui a le plus
complexe mais c'est quelque chose qui
est impressionne on va faire ça avec des
cinq six ans développement de la
motricité travaille en équipe réflexion
mathématique voilà selon Chloé les
bienfaits de ce jeu de construction pour
les plus jeunes mais pas seulement le
Kapla est aussi utilisé dans les écoles
d'architecture pour réaliser des
maquettes et quand on vous dit que les
adultes gardent toujours une âme
d'enfant
l'actualité du jour c'est cette visite
dans les quartiers de la secrétaire
d'État à la ville une visite qui s'est
terminée en toute fin d'après-midi afin
de constater les réalisations dans le
cadre de la loi d'orientation et de
programmation de la rénovation urbaine
Myriam el khomri était cet après-midi et
attrape elle a également rencontré les
habitants Anthony Rey chez Patrick
Jacques de Dixmude
il y a 66 entreprises
il y a encore 5 ans les bâtiments de
cette pépinière d'entreprises
n'existaient pas ils ont pu voir le jour
grâce au programme de l'Agence nationale
de rénovation urbaine la rue avait alors
pour objectif de désenclaver les
quartiers dissensibles je pense que
trappes a encore besoin du soutien
notamment de l'Agence nationale de
renouvellement urbain en termes de
rénovation urbaine encore des choses à
finir à Trappes et puis là on lance une
grosse dynamique aussi autour des
contrats de villes et je crois que ce
qui est important c'est que l'urbain
soit au service de l'humain et qu'il
faut aussi favoriser une présence
massive des services publics sur cette
ville favoriser des actions favoriser
des subventionnés aussi les associations
pour qu'il y ait plus de liens social
pour recréer ce lien social au sein de
ces quartiers sensibles en février
dernier le gouvernement a mis en place
les contrats villes un dispositif qui
regroupe le renouvellement urbain le
développement économique et cohésion
sociale si dans quelques mois la commune
de Trappes aura terminé le processus de
rénovation urbaine prévue dans le
contrat signé en 2006 il reste encore
trois chantiers la cité nouvelle et les
square Camus et Vedrine avec ce nouveau
contrat ville la commune 5 continents
souhaite axer ses projets pour le futur
sur l'éducation et l'intégration
républicaine tout ce qui est
compréhension de de notre société je
parle de la maison des parents je parle
des centres sociaux culturels tout ce
qui est
participation à la vie publique ça passe
par des choses aussi aussi simple
apparemment mais aussi compliqué dans la
réalité de comprendre le français dans
le cadre des contrats villes le
gouvernement prévoit de débloquer 400
millions d'euros pour redynamiser
l'emploi
et pour accueillir la secrétaire d'État
vous l'avez vu Benoît Hamon le député
des Yvelines anciens ministres à
l'originière d'une vaste polémique en
affirmant que le la politique de
l'exécutif menaçait la République depuis
Jean-Christophe Cambadélis premier
secrétaire du PS appelé à l'Union
message entendu visiblement les échanges
entre l'ancien ministre et la secrétaire
d'État sont restés courtois le journal
revient vendredi en marge de l'actualité
du jour nous reviendrons bien sûr sur
l'essentiel de la semaine ce soir sur
TVfil 78 un nouveau numéro de philico
présenté préparé par Floran parfait
bonne soirée